[Music]
[Applause]
uh we're trying to get the microphone
situated here with uh Ryan Leaf I don't
know if Ryan broke it but uh let's see
he didn't break it okay all right that's
why we can't have nice things not a good
sign though of Paul's being The Tech Guy
that's things things have gone a skew
speaking of wonky things have gone a
skew all right I'll come in and fix it
do you want to we'll just it what you
just hold the microphone there ran how's
how's that okay uh how about we turn on
his microphone here this one here yeah
all right what do we have all right live
live television live television
everybody all right but the thing is you
want you want this that's The Dan
Patrick Show oh yeah you need that yeah
uh Ryan is of course college football
NFL analyst for Westwood one and NFL
Network and the uh CEO of Ram consultant
Incorporated college football and NFL
analyst you can see him on good morning
football good to see you again um let me
start with the college football weekend
Notre Dame and USC if you were Notre
Dame and your game planning for
USC what would you do well I would uh I
would attack their defense because
that's where that's where they're so
vulnerable I I don't think they're bad
defensively Dan I think that
unfortunately Alex wrench he he tends to
get he's the defensive coordinator he
tends to get a little too complicated
you see him running some different
schemes defensively and that leaves gaps
open all over the field when they're
talented enough I mean they recruit well
enough to have the right guys there to
do the work that they need to do but he
just gets them into some awkward
situations and all of a sudden they're
being gashed because the Gap Integrity
is lost and the offense is relying
totally now on Caleb Williams to save
them and with what they have over the
next six weeks that's going to be really
difficult I I actually see them probably
losing maybe three of the six games here
down the stretch USC yeah loses three I
don't I don't think they I I don't think
they escape South band actually well
Notre Dame's favored by three by the way
who came up with gap
Integrity um I believe it was uh
Socrates yeah but but but what it sounds
like a Mike Mayo well soon as it was
said all analysts jump to it so I'm I'm
I'm guilty of that as well I don't know
what Gap integrity means okay like uh
you know when somebody has Integrity
it's good stuff like good Integrity
right Gap Integrity is about good you
know good solid uh in your right gap on
the defensive side of the football when
you do not have Gap Integrity why do why
why do we need to say what would you use
something else they were in the wrong
spot just say in the wrong spot yeah yes
yeah I don't because it's it's analystic
like we're going to throw the ball you
know vertically yeah okay yeah I'm going
to take the top off the D like it feels
like you know three three techniqu guy I
think what you just you know you yeah
I'm guilty of it too I i' I've been
swayed by the the Gap Integrity
conversation probably heard it from
orlovski I I tend to take a lot of stuff
from orlovski because he's really good
at it and uh uh so yeah that's probably
where I got it for but it feels like
it's a secret language that anal like
only analysts have this you can't use
this just us the guys who you know we
played we know what set the edge me like
what are we doing yeah the set the edge
part I was like just just just make sure
he doesn't get outside you you know it's
like everybody's got to have their
favorite what did uh what were the other
ones that Mayo would have oily hips
waist Bender oh waist Bender was big and
oily
hips oily hips huh that was my problem I
didn't have oily hips guys that was the
problem we finally figured it out
figured it out after 25 years but we got
it um who did we have on who was falling
in love with Drake May with was that
orlovski orlovski likes Drake it feels
like he likes him more than he does
Caleb Williams okay the thing my guy is
Michael penck Jr so so that's where we
would you take him over these other two
I'd take penck over both of them if you
had the number one pick in the draft yes
you would take Michael Pennock yes
because of what kayin dor does
offensively with Ryan grub it's a very
Pro style offense also he doesn't get
sacked he gets the ball out of his hand
and that doesn't mean just quickly
sometimes it's down the field uh um for
Big Shots quickly out of he does not get
sacked the last two years you look at
what Caleb Williams has had to do you're
not going to be able to do that in the
NFL where you're going to be able to go
backwards run all over the place and
make a play now maybe he will but it
hasn't been sustainable for a lot of
guys I mean Patrick Mahomes uses it when
he needs to it seems like Caleb Williams
has to do it all the time I think Drake
May is probably a good fit there as well
in terms of what he can do um uh you
know but I think he's a lot like Sam how
I do I think they're very similar just
not only because they're from North
Carolina Michael penck Jr for me and
this is hard for me to say you know
being a Washington Husky uh rocking a
coug shirt on on your show here um but
but I I just like him a lot and I love
what kayin dbor and Ryan grub bring to
the table in terms of their offensive
philosophy and what it can look like
when it translates to the NFL game I
like that okay because I I agree with
you Caleb Williams won't be able to play
This Way in the NFL no he may have
moments
plays that he can play like this but you
know the game is just so much quicker as
you know getting ball out you know your
reads when you throw it away all of
those things but orlovski loved Drake
may I haven't I haven't studied him
enough I've been breaking down a little
bit of what the Miami UNC matchup is for
this weekend just because of what went
down with Miami last week because I
wanted this game to be such a big deal
in last week's decision by Mario crisol
kind of put that to the side a little
bit you know and hopefully it won't beat
him twice so this I think this will go a
long way for Drake May if he can have a
a really good game against the likes of
the Miami Hurricanes in a division or in
a conference and then you know hopefully
they'll get to a a championship game
against Florida state who's really good
so you just so I have it correct if you
had the number one pick in the draft and
needed a quarterback you would take
Michael Pennock Jr yeah he he to me is a
you know Trevor Lawrence he to me is
Andrew Luck that's that's what I believe
in him I mean it's not the same but you
know the Heisman Trophy um sounds are
starting to come out a lot louder around
Michael pen junr I think he's like the
number two guy right now I think he
might be number one and I I tell you if
they now he's got a great opportunity
they got Oregon at home this weekend
right this is the fir like the fifth top
10 matchup at Husky Stadium ever it's
going to be a huge huge deal close game
they beat him in Eugene last year then
he's got a November 11th matchup at SC
against uh Caleb Williams He Go goes
down there they win and he beats the
Rainy Heisman Trophy winner his his
stock is going to Skyrocket and so I'm
just I'm trying to get on that train
earlier than than most we're talking to
Ryan Leaf joining us uh in a Washington
state grad yeah um I I don't understand
the battle going on with you and game
day with Washington State I'm I I took
the high road on that thing I just I
said hey you know I didn't like that you
didn't celebrate our team and rather
than made it a joke that was my that was
the only thing I said I love game day uh
I love Kirk herb Street and but I
thought they were jabbing the Pack 12
not Washington State coach Corso Is So
Pro college football from the standpoint
he doesn't say negative things I'm
watching that live and I thought he said
the nobody wants us B he does no he says
nobody watch he says nobody wants this
bll I think he says nobody
watches and maybe other way okay I think
I think dickert heard no one watches us
bowl and what he really said was no one
wants us bull because no one wants those
two teams he's correct he's correct okay
but what he did afterward and the the
the CME and then McAfee kind of jumping
on that okay I was I didn't like that
part I just you know was my alma moer
these kids didn't even be made fun of
you had a chance to celebrate him so I
said something do you want a piece of
McAfee um no I don't uh as my wife has
told me over and over stay away from
that that is bad karma and uh and she's
right she's right she's absolutely right
let's bring in Pat McAfee Paulie hey Pat
M um I uh I just wanted to celebrate
college football and and unfortunately
but they double down on it too so I just
I've let them kind of run with it and uh
you know yeah they they're not letting
go no and uh you know unfortunately you
know that's uh that's that's I love I
love
college football games you know I love
doing that and uh you know that's that's
that's the disappointing part in all
this help me understand this that Kell
Moore was the offensive coordinator with
the Cowboys now he's with the Chargers
the Chargers play the Cowboys on Monday
night how
much input information do you think is
relevant to what he knows about the
Cowboys to what then he can give to his
team well I don't think he can
necessarily give anything to his team I
I don't I don't buy into that a lot
because the game too fast uh trying to
tell tell somebody in a weak lead up to
a game what they're going to do in this
that's that's not going but is there a
Cadence that you can get is there
signals there maybe Cadence but I will
say this he has gone up against Dan
Quinn in that defense every day in
practice for the last two years so he
has an understanding of how to call
offense against that I'm not so um
partial to the idea that he's going to
be able to tell the defense what Matt
McCarthy's going to be able to do okay
he knows what Quinn his Tendencies are
more or less because he went against him
every day I mean they put practice
scripts against one another for three
years together or whatever it was so
that for me is more beneficial than him
being able to tell the defense what M
Mike McCarthy is going to call or do
with a player's tendency that's where I
think the success comes from they get
Austin Eckler back Justin Herbert is a
stud uh you know hopefully Quinton
Johnston is going to be able to to add
to the mix now that that Mike Williams
is is out why don't we celebrate Austin
Eckler the way we do Christian mcaffrey
um he wasn't a first round pick maybe
but his numbers are better than
Christian McCaffrey I it's just a it's a
mindset thing it really is the the
anchor that you wear both good and bad
when it comes to being a top draft pick
it it's it's it's a branding thing and
the other thing is it just maybe not as
excitable I love Austin Eckler and what
he brings to the table well mcaffrey has
a novelty to him being a white running
back he does he does and uh and to be
the best running back in the NFL right
now in terms of of his production that
that you know leads to the the the Great
White Hope mentality yeah but Austin
Eckler has put up these great numbers I
agree with and then tried to get a new
contract the Chargers like yeah see what
you can get and then he has to crawl
back and now he gets you know this a big
moment for him Standalone game it's a
huge moment he hasn't played since week
one but he was great in that game he's
been banged up a little bit now he gets
to do it on Monday night football
against the America's team who's coming
off
just an absolute embarrassment in San
Francisco so I mean this is this is big
for both squads um you know me I'm a
huge huge fan of Justin Herbert I just
love watching the guy play I love the
guy that he is um I don't know if I've
ever seen anything so substantial that
when he got hammered on the sideline by
the Las Vegas Raider guy the entire yeah
team came to his Aid I mean that if that
didn't showcase how beloved that's a
good sign he is in that locker room for
that organization did you ever get
knocked down close to the sidelines and
waited for your teammates to get up and
get somebody's face um I can't at the
NFL level I would assume no one came to
pick me up um but in college in college
my Five Guys up front uh they were they
they they literally laid down in traffic
for me uh one point do you remember the
the movie The
Program um I I know it yeah so initially
when it was first released there's a
scene there's a scene in it they're
laying in traffic well the quarterback
says that to him he goes what what are
you willing to do for me and they go
down and lay down in literal traffic
like down the well apparently after that
scene ran kids went out and tried it
someone got injured and hurt and so they
pulled the scene from the from the movie
but me and the old lineman went and saw
it like we literally did that I walked
out of it and I was like what are you
guys willing to do for me here just
idiotic 19-year-old kids probably you
know you know h up on some Bush light I
don't know and and and we went lay down
in traffic in Moscow Idaho but it I mean
it didn't dear to that they were the fat
five two of them were
Walk-Ons I mean those guys we went to
battle Yeah they uh they stood up for me
a ton not only in games but off the
field as well go way yeah good guys I've
asked the danet what are they willing to
do for me hey you know what I I think
that I think that you over I I think
that you're not around when I spent time
with with a lot of them you know Paulie
and I go to dinner his daughters take
care of my son when we do and they they
you know they are they are very grateful
for you and they would probably do a lot
more than than you think yeah yeah
Paulie we had a talk and we may not lay
down in traffic but we'll sit through
traffic like a jam to get here to work
so to get to work they would sit in
traffic traffic that's something okay
you know a lot of people SE and fritzy
do sit in traffic when they they put a
lot of miles on my car prayers I've
turned back a couple times when when the
construction was too bad or I couldn't
get like you know I've bent uh uh
Paulie's ear about having two daughters
you have all daughters my wife and I
who's here in the green room we're about
to go to our 34 we ultrasound and it's
it's a little girl oh and so um they had
the shower and they brought home a lot
of the pink stuff and the and I just I
looked around for the first time I think
it finally hit me there's never been a a
girl in our family like my mom and dad
had three boys and then like all the
daughters of my grandparents had all
boys and so we've had a a cousin uh um
who's a girl in the family but no one
this will be the first one for me like
even having any tendency of like what am
I going to do so I think I'm going to
you know you guys are going to have to
be real mentors for me through this
process well I'll be uh more than happy
to do that I appreciate that that's
going to be so your son's name is
MacGyver your daughter going to have a
TV show like Buffy Vampire
Slayer I don't I mean we've we've told
people this but I don't know if if if
Anna wants me blabbing it out but she
was she's okay we we decided with the
Clayborn um and Bo was the the Bo and
the born was what my son gravitated to
so we started like at night he'll come
in talk to her belly and say hey Bo what
are you eating in there you have't Pizza
you know and and now and she's really
active and she's like punching and like
kicking and stuff so MacGyver can see it
and then um her middle name's going to
be Marvel so there's your but not
because of the movie because you know
you guys have known me long enough we we
struggled uh with four miscarriages
during the pandemic and so the fact that
this happened is a is a Marvel and so
that's what Anna wanted and so we're
going to go Clayborn Marvel leaf and uh
I would I I'm we both started talking
about this the other night we bet she
ends up walking out of there going
you're going to call me Marvel is what
you're going to call me it's like a
Kardashian name you know marvel I don't
think so yeah I think this is a leaf
name and we're we're happy about it
look at you doing big boy stuff yeah at
47 yeah I'll be 65 when she graduates
from high school all her friends are
going to be like hey your grandpa came
how cool uh I I've gone through that
you've gone through that one oh yeah oh
yeah I like oh who's grandfather's here
that's my dad man is he old um hey great
to talk to you you too good to see you
yes and uh we'll take a break we'll come
back with phone calls here Chase Daniel
is going to join us you have more
touchdown passes than Chase Daniel
somebody sent me that and I said no
you're wrong you're wrong about that how
many touchdown passes did you throw 14
14 Paulie now we can't include preseason
in this though Paulie if we went
preseason then I would have a lot I'm a
preseason Hall of Fame Chase is Tom
Brady too in the preseason yes he is
Chase Daniel might be might be the best
pre season quarterback of all time
pretty good I was pretty good though
Chase Daniel career touchdown passes
nine oh someone sent that to me and I
was like how many years did he play 15
yeah
15 13 well well he was on a team for 13
years yeah but he played he got to he
got paid to play professional football
for 13 years or whatever it was he went
two and three as a starter I went uh 4
and 17 so I beat beat him there
too hey the days turning up for me boys
yeah things are looking up uh thank you
Ryan thank you guys Ryan Lea joining is
we're back after this